hey reject nation I'm Greg Alba and I'm
John Humphrey we are going to watch
today a long video Kingdom Hearts story
summary what you need to know to play
Kingdom Hearts 3 see at our patreon we
do a lot of coverage of things we do TV
show reaction watch along for many of
shows that includes my hero academia
attack on Titan Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood as well as supernatural
Gotham and Riverdale as well as weekly q
and A's and John has plenty of music
video coverage one of our top reward
tiers whatever video you request we must
definitely do and put up on the youtubes
and today comes an obnoxiously long one
from a man named Michael B who we have
obnoxiously long conversations I'm
constantly messaging this guy throughout
the week we go back and forth one I've
liked a couple of people over there who
are like pen pals based off the amount
that we talk with each other and Michael
B is definitely one of them you should
go check out his channel this guy really
knows his stuff when it comes to movies
and TV shows on media I'm telling you
guys like in the description box well
worth it if he stays consistent he's
gonna be a huge YouTube or someone who I
think if he moved to LA or something
you'd be collabing with people left and
right he's a damn good youtuber and I
hope you guys go check him out it's all
someone start us as well Michael B love
you buddy
I've never play Kingdom Hearts played
the first one way back in the dia one
two three around the corner oh boy
time to go over the sagas famously
complex storyline so get ready because
we're going to tackle this series from
start to finish this is what you need to
know about the kingdom are white faced
erections in the age of fairy tales when
the world was whole
Kingdom Hearts a massive collection of
Hearts was the source of all light and
dust wisdom and power Kingdom Hearts at
a counterpart in the form of the X Way
which also served as its protector the
master of masters an elusive prophet
studied the x-blade and discovered a way
to create a weapon called the Keyblade
in the image of the X played by
extracting it from a person's heart the
master of masters saw a devastating
battle of horizon which would bring
forth the end of the world he trained
five of his apprentices named the
foretellers
to each lead a separate union to protect
the world and its light from the
approaching darkness he gave each of
them their own Keyblade as well as a
special role including giving one member
Liu Shu the Keyblade in which he had
placed his Daisy I giving the master of
masters knowledge of any event this
Keyblade with no name observed he also
gave Liu Shu a special black box that he
cannot open but seemingly knows the
contents of after reciting these roles
to his and practices master of masters
disappears leaving the foretellers to
carry out the roles he gave to them
however shortly after one of the four
tellers
ira discovers a nightmare a dark version
of a creature called a dream eater which
exists to plant bad dreams upon those
who sleep now it leads the group to
believe that there is a traitor in their
ranks after the group fractures under
this pressure conflicts begin to raise
between the five unions and the master
of masters true intentions seem to be
shown one for teller Ava gathers various
powerful Keyblade wielders who show
resistance to the growing darkness and
convinces them to go into hiding instead
of fighting naming this new underground
group the dandelions as the union's
fought each other for control of the
world's light or Lux in order to fight
off
growing darkness the fractured efforts
only allowed the darkness to overtake
the entire world this was called the
Keyblade war and it eventually caused
the x-blade to shatter into 20 pieces
seven of perla ham 13 of pure darkness
without its protector Kingdom Hearts
disappeared into the darkness after the
battle the world was saved by the light
within the hearts of children however
not full moon world was splitting as by
a disconnected words the dilapidated
battleground that once hosted the
Keyblade war was then known as the
Keyblade graveyard filled with the key
blades of those who failed in the war
the remaining wielders the dandelions
vowed to protect the world from further
destruction and later worked to reunite
the unions
years later when the events of the
Keyblade war were no only as legend a
young man on the Destiny islands known
as Zion works was paid a visit by a
mysterious cloaked figure as it turns
out this figure was a being named axel
a form of Zane or its future self
travelled back in time
handsome is a being called a heartless
which is essentially a living
manifestation of the darkness within
someone's heart and some grants a
marquis ability to travel through time
in order to gather ten vessels to house
fragments of his future selfs heart in
order to create an organization that
could recreate the x-blade and restart
the Keyblade war after travelling
through time and returning later loses
his memory of the events but carries the
subconscious desire to become a keyblade
master and carry out the events that
would lead to this foreseen future
Ansem also returns to his own time Zanna
travels to the land of departure and
trans to become a keyblade master along
with his fellow pupil and friend Erika's
the friendship between the two begins to
fracture however when Erika's believes
that the darkness of the world should be
eliminated rezian art believes it could
be controlled than that instead of
eliminating darkness it should instead
exist in equilibrium with light and
aging Zayin work then takes an
apprentice name Ventus the sole purpose
of using his body
Ventus be a Freddy's rc2 however Ventus
proves to be too weak for this purpose
and same art instead extracts the
darkness from his heart is create a new
being known as vanitas beyond the black
brain process also Britt's a new breed
of being called the Unversed
creatures attracted to negativity
Ziggler decides to use mad at us to
recreate the ecstasy by combining his
heart into pure darkness with a heart of
pure light which he would find later Zen
mark takes Memphis to destiny islands to
die but there his broken heart is
unknowingly touched by a newborn baby
named Sora whose heart laments his own
so a rose that is to survive insane art
instead takes the point Ericka's to be
trained with his other two pupils terra
and aqua Ziebart seized one of the gulf
Atlantis's
tara is a suitable vessel after the
failure ventus and he begins to
manipulate him into turning against his
friends whoa during this period Tara
visits dust in the islands and meets a
young boy named Riku
Terra performs a ceremony called the
decree thing a ritual in which a
keyblade master or somewhat of an equal
level as someone touched their keyblade
to here at the power to that's not a
quick release reaches the heat wave
called kingdom KATUSA also during this
time aqua ends up in radiant garden and
finds a young girl named Kyrie who
accidentally I really play the quiescent
hurry
allowing the Keyblade to choose her in
the process meanwhile Erika's attempts
to kill Ventus to prevent it from being
used to create the x-blade and
ultimately lead to total destruction but
he's stopped by Tara Zane arrives and
kills air gifts and ghosts here to meet
him through the Keyblade graveyard where
aqua and Ventus follow at the Keyblade
graveyard
Zadora transpose his heart into Tara's
body to become Terezin are so
entertaining all this informations come
out of the darkness it was lost to
during the Keyblade war and it appears
in the sky however
and by another Keyblade apprentice
Mickey Mouse defeat van insists to share
with the x-blade
tournament worlds and causing Kingdom
Hearts to disappear once again ah then
just his heart is lost after the battle
with mantis and Mickey Bruce ended up
what to the mysterious tower there aqua
weeks yen sid a retired Keyblade master
who trained Mickey and words that Ventus
has fallen into deep sleep until his
heart is able to recover aqua returns to
the land of departure to seal it away as
she was instructed to do by air kiss
before his death she transforms the land
of departure into Castle oblivion
creating the chamber of waking where she
seems ventus's body while it heals she
then goes to reading garden with Tara
say in Northland
samer eventually escapes from aqua but
loses his memories due to tears heart
resisting his control he is then
discovered by Ansem the wise a different
handsome than we've seen before who
takes him up as his apprentice ventus's
heart then finds its way back to sora
merging with this heart in order to heal
aqua heads up in the realm of darkness
pretties covers a time know a couple
family feeling like Ginn's to relive all
of this as masters and he along with
another apprentice of Ansem sprang
convinced Ansem to experiment with the
heart in order to extract its darkness
to create carpets hansen becomes wise to
their plan however that refuses
unfortunately Xander Greg and Anselm's
of their apprentices create organization
xiii and banished Ansem the wise to the
realm of darkness Zen art takes Anselm's
name and identity then extracts the
darkness out of himself and his fellow
apprentices creating both heartless as
well as nobodies or the shell of the
body after the heart has been removed
Xena was heartless retains the name and
identity of an
and afterwards now split into both a
heartless and a nobody the heartless of
two handsome begins to lead a car these
are bused across many worlds in anbar me
awhile Hartman is possible to create his
own artificial kingdom hearts built
artisan sets up to find more nobodies to
join his organization 13 elsewhere Ansem
the wise discards a stolen name
harnesses the power of the darkness but
doesn't let it consume him and escapes
the realm of darkness to Twilight time
he takes the named is an acronym for
darkness and zero and disguises himself
in a red robe and mask to conceal his
identity he takes refuge in an abandoned
mansion and dedicates his time to
researching the nobodies and the
heartless nine years later Sora
the boy who ventus's heart and taken
refuge is preparing to leave his home
world of destiny items with his friend
Riku the boy Terra bequeathed and Kyrie
the girl who walked with acquiesced been
eventually washed up on the island when
Rikuo
Isidore the secret place of the island
succumbing to the darkness he allows the
Heartless to invade the island sora
reaches up to touch riku's heart and in
the process shows riku's keyblade the
Suzuki vodka starter that I had to die
stood in Tiffany yeah movement with the
Keyblade Sora is able to fend off the
ensuing army before he finds Kyra near
the door which blows open created an
explosion of darkness that destroys the
islands influence or out to sea Hart
takes refuge inside Sora for protection
and her physical body as well as Ritu
are blasted the locations unknown
meanwhile Mickey Mouse
now again master a king of his world has
left his home to deal with the growing
the virus you left instructions for his
mage Donald Duck and Knight goofy to
find the key and they set out to
traverse town
many of those whose worlds has been
destroyed were they made up of Sora by
coincidence after discovering that
sorters keyblade can be used to seal the
phenols prevent them from being
overtaken by purpose the drink come
across Maleficent reveals that she is
seeking out the seven princesses of
hearts to unlock the keyhole that leads
to the artificial kingdom hearts that
Hanson created at the end of the world
the seven princesses as it turns out
were protected by the seven fragments of
pure light that broke off of the
original x-blade sort of discuss that
Riku had joined Miletus senator hunt as
she had promised to help him find and
rescue Kyrie in exchange for his efforts
Riku later finds Kyrie but with her
heart seemingly missing from her body
ah Sora and his team eventually arrive
at Hollow Bastion the base of Ansem and
Maleficent operations and the site of
what remains of radiant garden and take
on Riku Riku is bested by Sora and
leaves with ansa sort of the aether with
us again once again behind Riku who
leads him to Congress most of his body
Riku then reveals himself to be
possessed by answer who explains that
Kyrie is in fact a princess apart and
informed Sora that carries heart is
currently inside of him
sorry defeat Sansom but cannot see a
hollow bastions keyhole to the Coyotes
heart remaining in his body
Sora uses Anselm's Keyblade to unlock
his heart releasing his encounters heart
of the process this event however turn
Sora into a heartless damn restart our
body waves as the strength as a princess
apart to return Sora to assume informed
of the fragments of worlds taken by the
Heartless he is found and defeated by
Sora
however Ansem manages to open the door
to his artificial kingdom hearts but is
quickly killed but
revealed inside Mickey and Riku back in
his own body are seen through the door
in the run of darkness a swarm of
heartless rise in attempt to attack Ryu
but aqua would have met up with Miki
previously sacrifices herself to keep
them from reaching it what the human
Miki men help Sora close the door to
prevent the darkness inside from escape
Sora seals the door with Mickey and Riku
inside with the promise from Mickey that
there will always be a door for the
light and that he will see his friends
again after the door is sealed the
broken worlds reunite
nakiya is pulled back to the destiny
islands with Sora promising that they
will meet again someday Sora Donald and
Goofy then set off to find the heavily
discovered their friends back in the
realm of darkness to help anybody else
she encounters them unbeknownst to Sora
when he unlocked his heart he created a
nobody for both he and Kylie named Roxas
and nominated respectively shortly after
the election nominee is found in the
floors of Castle oblivion my
organization xiii and is taken captive
oh boy this is found in twilight town by
zenith and recruited as a member of the
organization
Roxas due to being sword as nobody as
well as ventus's heart and having Sora
is able to wield both Sora and ventus's
keyblades this play started the care of
axel another member of organization xiii
old who are tasked with destroying
heartless in order to release their
captive hearts which the organization
can use to create another artificial
Kingdom Hearts and become complete
beings as opposed to nobodies once again
shortly after Roxas is induction into
the organization a new member named
Shion joins as well Shion is a
mysterious person whose appearance
changes based on the preceptors
relationship she when she is happy with
the wield a keyblade
shortly after axel and several other
members of the organization are set to
castle oblivion to look after not
and prepare for the arrival of Sora Sora
Donald and Goofy make their way to
Castle oblivion but upon entering they
lose their memories and they are
replaced by fabrications created by
nominee who was forced to do so by her
captors to organization members from our
luck sianeth our scene plan to use
nominative wipe Sora's memories to use
him as a puppet to overthrow the
organization her and his friends fight
their way through the castle defeating
various organization members along the
way and eventually nominee is free she
instructs Sora and his friends to enter
memory pods so that they can sleep will
nominate repairs their memories causing
them to lose on memory for his result
monka who appeared at the lowest level
of castle oblivion fights his way up to
Sora in the memory pots but refuses to
see his darkness inside his heart
instead leaving and telling nominate to
take care of Sora while Sora's puts
asleep
Roxas falls into a deep coma for several
weeks due to their connection meanwhile
in an attempt to get back at the
organization dis invades castle oblivion
to fight Sora whom he had observed up to
this point as well as dominate and he
takes them both back to Twilight town to
oversee the reconstruction of Sora's
memories after waking Roxas is informed
of the organization's loss at castle
oblivion including the elimination of
all of the members set there except for
axel Roxas begins to spend time with she
on an axle and the three grow close
shortly after alexis begins to
experience Sora's memories as they are
restored in Sora and he starts to
question the motives of the organization
eventually she noted he has renewed who
calls her existence into question we can
later finds her unconscious
destiny islands and asks her to come
with him to fight Sora in order to
return the memories of his back to him
so he can awaken confused as to why she
has soared as memories in the first
place and not wanting to leave her
friends she ever returns to the
organization with Sora's memories begin
to absorb faster into her instead of
Roxas making her grow strong well he
grows weak which was the culture sighs
this events nominees efforts to restore
these memories it destroyed shortly
after her return she leaves once again
with Riku to go find Sora
later axel reveals to Roxas she hunts
true identity and in perfect replica of
rocks is created by xemnas as a
fail-safe if he failed offset that
excellent Milnes but kept it from him
Roxas bakes axel to reveal his true
identity as well axel refuses and Roxas
follows she has lead and defects from
the organization despite excellent
working that the organization would
destroy him for this betrayal meanwhile
she makes her way to Twilight Talyn
finds nómine in the old mansion
now many tells she got what she really
is and informs her that when she returns
to sora everyone's memory of her it will
be for God
oh I accept his sacrifice and begins to
go with Sora before she was able to
however dis informed them that the
organization has followed her she had
discover sided his in fact axel would
follow her with the intention to bring
her back to the organization
- I know thio is its deficit iki jobs
excellency it's a British I'm back to
xemnas at the organization's world the
world that never was
missile faced from exhaustion but Zen is
fine Shion and begins to reprogram
shortly after she shrinks won't pick it
up she's taken on an altered form not
resembling Sora almost exactly although
a reprogrammed Shion is still aware that
if she continues to exist
Roxas will eventually fade away so she
tricks him into a battle and forces him
to defeat her in self-defense after the
bad
chiana in his arms as she fades
returning the memories and the heart she
grew to sora consequently Roxas loses
his memories / she asks them to prevent
some obtaining kingdom hearts and
expresses her gratitude for his and axes
friendship before disappearing
completely this first game will he
remember that it was I feel like it's
been hopping around in the old frog
holidays or as I can't remember exactly
if like to influence case I speak more
style rocks and said any cost as she
believes he is not ready to take on
service yet Roxas overpowers Riku so
Rika reduces blindfold and taps into the
darkness in his heart transforming into
a new form resembling Ansem who now
resides within Riku Riku ultimately
defeats Roxas and disappears and opens a
portal back to the old mansion where he
takes Roxas knowing that the
organization will always be on the hunt
for axis does digitize the semi and
places him in a virtual Twilight town
inside the digital world
Roxas lives out a seemingly normal
summer vacation without any memories of
this time with the organization again
roxrite as much as I do not sore as hell
as nominee as the story the outside soon
nobody's begin to invade his town along
with axel who were set there by the
organization after finally discovering
room access was hit Roxas is surprised
when a keyblade appears to help them
fend off this awesome and due to an
interruption by diz Axel's unable to
retrieve Roxas returning to the
organization empty-handed
Laxus also comes in contact with nominee
which connects his heart with Kyrie
nominees true counterplay Kyrie is able
to use this connection to communicate
with Roxas and what she asks about Sora
he is able to communicate through boxes
and speak to her as more and more
anomalies in the digital Twyla
to take effect such as time-freezing and
other various glitches not only
eventually reveals the truth to Roxas
she informs him that he isn't nobody and
that he will one day meet with the boy
he sees in his dreams
sore axel appears again threatening your
axis that if he does not return to the
organization actually be forced to
eliminate dizzy ravines once more
however and tells Roxas to meet him at
the old mansion freezing axel and the
rest of the world in its tracks Maxis
complies and meets nominate at the old
mansion and she tells him that reuniting
with Sora will not cause him to
disappear but instead make him holding
disappears to take nominate away but not
before she tells him that they
one day even if they don't recognize
each other Roxas eventually regain lost
memories and realizes that nómine was
telling that she was about him living in
a simulation and being placed there by
Diaz in a cloak man who in actuality is
Rican
Roxas finds necessary and destroys it in
Acre although it is just a digital copy
axel appears one more time and the two
shelf regaining his memories Roxas is
able to fight to his full ability
including summoning both of his key
blades Roxas defeats axel who retreats
Roxas expresses that he hopes to see
excellence someday but he replies that
only Roxas has the next life
Roxas enters the room or Sora's kept
finding a sleeping Donald and Goofy
along the way disk read some as he
arrives and go sit with remarks about
his purpose and existence boxes begins
to attacked is revealing that he is just
a hologram Roxas continues the assault
until dis disappears and in his place a
pot opens in the center of the room
discipline side Roxas finally sees a
sleeping Sora Roxas accepts his fate
purpose and smiled sadly stating that a
summer vacation is over well he had Sora
a sword to use to awake he tears Roxas
call out his name confused he opens his
eyes to instead see his friends Donald
and Goofy calling for Sora and his
friends then beat yet SiC who informs
them of their opposition namely the
Heartless the nobodies in organization
13 then Sora Donald and Goofy once again
set off to protect various worlds to the
heartless man now discovered that there
are two groups one led by the
organization and a by a recently revived
Maleficent elsewhere axel travels to
destiny islands to find Kairi luring her
with a promise to see Sora in an attempt
to kidnap her
Rico is able to stop this by creating a
corridor of Darkness transporters
Twilight town
she's shortly found once again by axel
who successfully captures her shortly
after she's taken by psychics
right-hand man and axis former friend
meanwhile Howell bastion restoration
committee is formed to restore hollow
past five minutes for a oriental art
this committee includes Sora Donald and
goofy but also some of the various
inhabitants of Trevor's talents or a map
at the beginning it was dirty after
fighting handsome the wisest secret lab
including his computer ends a more
experienced notes of the Heartless the
committee discovers that the world is
being attacked by heartless they fend
off the attack to find xemnas Nicky runs
after him and quickly thereafter
together
Donald and Goofy find themselves
surrounded by a massive artists are like
Game of Thrones off the attack and
eventually catch up to Mickey
Zenoss stalks the group implying that
Nicky knows more about still disagree
cooze location than he lets on before
vanishing in a corridor of darkness with
Mindy in tow the trio are then accosted
by Axl who tries to help them by
revealing the organization's plans but a
stop by science science instead reveals
the organization's intent to Sora to use
the power of Sora's Keyblade to capture
the whole thing to stop as much to the
sides under physics what decide the
goose dies suddenly maleficent appears
to summon her own carcass against
science but he is able to summon
nobody's that dispatched and easily
maleficent then attempts to hold off the
nobodies on her own
telex order to escape and find a way to
defeat the organization while putting a
corridor of darkness Beneatha taking
them to the rough darkness which sword
is able to escape to safety using his
Keyblade
Sora resumes his quest to rid various
worlds apart
nobody's eventually making his way back
to Twilight town where he ends up at the
old mansion with hater pets and Alette
rocks as his friends in the simulation
they are ambushed by a group of nobodies
but mickey arrives to the safe and the
group make their way into the basement
no man should make advances computer yet
they used to end of the simulation
inside they are again ambushed but this
time by an overwhelming horde of nobody
they are mission axel arrives and
sacrifices himself to eliminate the
board and save sora while underground
fading away he apologizes for kidnapping
Kairi revealing her location to Sora
he reveals that he did it because he
wanted to see Roxas again but admits
that sword makes him feel the same way
Rock system but he had a heart with his
final moments axel opens a portal to the
organization's world the world that
never was after arriving Roxas awakens
inside of Sora and transports him to the
depths of his heart they're rocks is ask
Sora my axel chose to save Sora instead
of transforming it into a heartless to
bring Roxas back before the party back
in the real world Sora Donald and Goofy
meet up a bathroom that make their way
to the organization stronghold the
Castleman was where the New Kingdom
Hearts is nearly complete inside Kyrie
is freed from her captivity by nominee
who opens a quarter of Darkness she uses
to escape the two are confronted by
psychics again but are saved to a
cloaked figure who turns out to be Riku
still resembling zan or as heartless so
had his friends reached the castle and
Mickey runs ahead to make this as Sora
fights his way through psychics
eventually corners
and sixes for the heart of summer while
Maleficent interlac EP take the
opportunity my sword fights through the
heartless eventually making his way to
the upper level where he finally
reunites with Kairi and Riku the group
make their way through the castle to
Phoenix several organization members
along the way including science there
Rika reveals to sort of the truth about
his and Roxas connection informing him
that Roxas is now defended
they reach dibs now a masked assassin to
wise once again along with Mickey who
are trying to seal them to became the
heart causing an encoding device the
machine begins to overload however just
as Ennis arrives at Miss Anne and some
argue over who was at fault for the
destruction of so many worlds in the
events Hey getting closer to bubbly and
some apologize sister boxes from what he
put him through hopefully the message
reaches in through Sora to ye that
explodes and has advantages the
explosion purifies Rika and returns it
to his true appearance but also damages
the New Kingdom Hearts
leashing a giant wave of heartless much
Melissa did Pete hold off allowing
everyone else to give chase to xemnas at
the very top of the castle they finds us
and Sora fights and ultimately defeats
her nemesis escapes through a door that
opened along with his kingdom hearts and
Sora and his friends enter it pursue
whoa whoa sorry we could defeat him once
again and he fades away everyone that
leaves through a quarter of Darkness the
before Sora Kairi and Riku are able to
nominate Roxas Roxas and nominate come
to peace of
with their respective others again
knowing that as long as surah and Kyrie
are together they can be together as
well
now many purchase with category in Roxas
five emerges with Sora Kairi leads the
group through the corridor but before
store and we can can enter it suddenly
closes his own distributors once again
togetherness or are able to ultimately
destroy sin this an organization xiii in
turn and escape to the edge of the realm
of darkness every basket there they
really rest I get some after Sora reads
it her moonlight bullets and reboots or
at length rule sending them back to
destiny eyes there they are reunited
with Donald goofy Mickey and better
graphics better game afterwards Julie
cricket who had been croc elasaur his
adventures in his journals well that one
he had written for their first journey
is now completely blank instead all the
journalists praise thank malady which he
had wrote himself is a reminder nobody
he would lose all memory of her after
there are deal in castle living in his
investigation into this line he finds
another that he didn't write their
hurting will be mended when you return
to nd to solve the mystery of this
mezzanine indicated justices the content
of the two journals and sends a virtual
version of Sora called data surah 4 days
s just in the islands to relive the
journal Sora's journeys and find out who
the her being are after carrying out the
events data sore meets a cloaked figure
who turns out to be a data version of
Roxas whom data Sora does not recognize
Dana Roxas helps data Sora open a door
which he precedes through to meet Dana
nominee she reveals to data Sora that
his real-life counterpart is the key
that connects everything due to his
connections with herself
Roxas exile and Shyam she also tells
datastore about Tara
Ventus and aqua were tied to Sora's
heart it is these seven figures that
real-life Sora must save from their
early data sorta thanks data nominee who
then erases herself from the nola
meanwhile Mickey beats with the n sip
they discussed finding Ventus
Terra and Aqua Mickey says that they may
be closer to knowing the location of
ventus's heart leaving the incident to
explain that now they only have to find
Terra revealing that the two are aware
although I got a neighbor in the
Hamptons
yes it also reveals to Mickey that
sensible Zane is heartless and nobody
had been destroyed by Sora and Riku his
heart and body can now merge to
reconstruct his original form
masters and yet said proclaims that this
threat is far too strong for only one
Keyblade master and orders Mickey to
summon Sora and Riku to undertake the
mark of mastery final test for those
tides of farm has become Keyblade
masters Mickey then writes a letter to
Sora of what he's learned and tells him
to bring Riku to meet with enemy and sit
he sends the message in a bottle to
destiny islands where wash is not sure
and is read by Sora Riku and Kairi in
the realm of darkness aqua still trapped
their flight's Ansem the wise who had
been transferred after that long
explosion caused by his trying to see of
kingdom hearts he reveals to her that
his memories are starting to fade but
tells her about a boy he met at least a
year ago with the Keyblade who has twice
saved the world from darkness she asks
if the boy's name is terror Ventus
but answer replies that it is neither he
then reveals that he had hit his
research within the boy while his
memories were being prepared and that he
hopes the boy will one day use this
knowledge to open the door to save him
and those that are connected to his
heart aqua asks the boy's name in answer
reveals to her that it is soul sorrow on
radiant garden in Hansen's lab the
members of organization 13 are revived
human form tv-10 abilities and heart
must be destroyed
Evan alias ienzo and Lee who was
executed form notice that members break
and Aiza Sciences human form are missing
they retain the memories of their nobody
forms but hold no grudge against sora
and riku Lee specifically remembers
McCool promises Riko we've been through
a lot it's fine Lee discusses with the
ends over break and I so might be and he
gets on forms to me that when a person
is reformed they will awaken on the
world in which they lost their heart in
the first place unless it has been
destroyed in which case they will awaken
in Traverse Town leaving remembers to
recognize that were invading a garden
when they became nobodies
so he leaves to go search for meanwhile
sora and riku appear before yen sid who
begins their mark of mastery exam the
trial sees the two to visit various
worlds that have been restored from the
heartless attack after their first
journey but have remained in a state of
deep sleep that disconnects them from of
the worlds Sora and Riku must awaken the
worlds can return them to the realm of
light by unlocking the seven keyholes
they find out these words should they do
this they will obtain the power required
to compete Saiyan work and be named
Keyblade masters they're then sent back
in time to destiny islands to enter the
realm of sleep along with the world soar
dives into the dreams of the worlds but
Rico unknowingly dives into Sora streets
instead becoming a Dream Eater and
protecting him from his nightmares
well-sorted Riku are away under exam
Mickey gets a letter informing him that
meeting has been kidnapped by making a
tenth I brush Donald and Goofy set off
to Disney Castle to rest here
once there Maleficent demands access to
the daily was created when he advertised
to disturb finally open the duckie
refuses and a quarter of Darkness opens
in which least chatrooms fly through why
people of
and causing her to peek describe the way
we emerges through the corridor and
Mickey recognizes in this axial lead
correction before the floorplan returned
to the mysterious castle to speak to
that sit there we request the incident
given the ability to whip the Keyblade
instead works in that this path will not
be easy but we persists as trade by
Merlin the wizard and the three good
fairies who use their magic to short the
trading period in the sleeping worlds
Sora Roxas encounter will say no it's
heartless and nobody along with
mysterious young man after they seal all
seven keyholes Sora is transported back
to the real world and to the world that
never was there Sora finds that brig has
once again become as nobody xigbar the
mysterious young man appears once again
and places Sora into a deep sleep
inside of this dream the young man
reveals himself to be a young masters
animal and he reveals to Sora his
ability to travel through time sort of
travels deeper and deeper into his own
dreams trying desperately to make it to
the castle however along the way he's
haunted by visions of nominated Roxas
Shion Terra aqua and Ventus
each weakening his heart upon reaching
the castle sort of finds both semanas
and xigbar who explained that the young
Zane or has been using his time
traveling ability to gather various
incarnations of Zane work to create a
new real organization how does you how
do these characters keep up with all
this I need somebody [ __ ] up your whole
planets of such members this axel Roxas
shion and others this plan eventually
fit you know what Abel feels the
obstacles Curtis has also revealed that
many nobodies rated to grow arms up
there
hooking axel Roxas nominating and Geum
nobody's it was a go her attempt to turn
Sora into what is a nerds vessels but he
refuses and does battle in zammis
although he is victorious the battle
does too much damage to his harvest he
falls into a comatose state
uh music brings him into the castle
there sort of falls into the darkness
but in order to protect him from being
swallowed whole by ventus's heart
lurches from surah and envelops in' in
ventus's keyblade meanwhile Brico after
sealing the seven keyholes also finds
himself inside the world that ever was
but inside sorters dreams there he finds
soros unconscious body floating within a
force field since Jung's a nordic
dragged him into some dreams so now a
shadow being emerges from Sora's
nightmare and Riku defeats it won't lead
to be dragged into the darkness by a
still lingering singer it's heartless
drag heartless reveals to recreate and
his dog Nations those worms nightmares a
longer exam say North's heartless
attempts to take over riku's body once
again but Rika was reminded of his
initial meeting with Terra as a child
and Alexa consumed his inner darkness
and returned it to life the to battle
once again and Riku purfles
returning out of service dreams into the
real world he makes this way to the
castles throne room a twenty nine sorta
still asleep
yo say in order Peters it reveals that
Sora will be used as his new thirteenth
vessel since usually you and Moses has
both failed in the past Young's an art
reveals the other versions abstainer to
Riku including a newly revived Masters
and Mickey arrives in an attempt to save
Riku and Sora but is stopped by a young
sailor who masters an orc has proves
consciousness within allowing him to
draw his Keyblade and do battle with
Riku Riku is victorious but at the time
the battle took place
Master Xehanort was fully revived Zener
reveals his ultimate goal to create the
thirteen darknesses to battle the seven
lights to recreate the x-blade and
restart the Keyblade war suddenly Saints
heart
and Xena described Riku and Mickey to
restrain them and master xandred
attempts to place a fragment of his
heart into Sora at the last moment
however Lee appears to protect Sora and
black Franklin Co the heart sends
another member of the organization after
Lee which turns out to be Sykes Isis
nobody Lee is able to dodge him and
ziggurat summons a powerful heartless to
defeat the group
well the goofy are able to arrive and
defeated however and masters in retreats
with his organization vowing that this
is only a temporary setback
and then his plan the group returned
against it at the mysterious tower with
Soros body and informed them of Master
Zen or its current scheme in order to
awaken Sora Riku must use the power he
obtained by sealing the seven keyholes
to dive inside source body to reassemble
his break apart inside Riku does battle
with Sora inside ventus's keyblade armor
which has been corrupted by a nightmare
this frees Sora but he disappears
causing Riku to use Sora's Keyblade to
enter a version of destiny islands here
Riku meets with what appears to be Roxas
ventus and Shion before finally meeting
with a data projection of Ansem the wise
this projection reveals that Rika was
actually accessing the research data
that the real handsome head inside Sora
while his memories were being restored
the ends of tell traumatic events or his
ability to connect with others hearts
and that disability along with the data
contained in a bottle given to Riku
might be able to bring back those who
have been lost and some finally reveals
that by defeating the nightmare and his
subsequent interactions with Roxas
ventus and Shion Rika was able to awaken
Sora in the real world
Rika returns to find an awakened Sora
celebrating the end of the exam yes that
means the results that won't both
or performed admirably only Rika was
declared a keyblade master as Sora
failed by falling to the darkness leave
that surprises the group I exclaimed
that he will be the next to attempt the
market mastered you he then summons his
Keyblade for the first time
Wow I was back to the sleepy trappers
town to visit his dream leaders
elsewhere in Castle oblivion a still
resting Ventus smiles as a result of
Sora's happiness back inside the tower
yet sit and Mickey discussed the history
of the Keyblade war and the exploit they
conclude that the center of princesses
of heart
let's tell me about the Keyblade the
story in detail the key Wars to me
problems for guests that yes it had
called for instead reveals that this
person can also build a keyblade and to
Riku and Mickey surprise
this person is Kyrie yet said better
feels that in order to protect the seven
princesses
they must rescue Ventus Terra and Aqua
Ventus is safely hidden away by aqua but
she has still lost in the realm of
darkness
Mickey BER tells his last experiences
with aqua revealing that she had
sacrificed herself to save Rika Rika was
upset at this information being kept
from him but is that informed by yen
said that it had to be hidden until the
safe means of entering the realm of
darkness was discovered he then informs
them that this means has been discovered
and recode Nicky are given protective
garments by the three good fairies
Merlin is also tasked with training
Kyrie and Lea and they all leave to
begin their assignments shortly after
sort of turns to the tower to reunite
with Goofy Donald and that's it
hell yeah that by nearly becoming Zane
its vessel Sora has been stripped of
many of the
it's an ability damn it yes it then
reveals that the data Ansem the wise
gave tarik who was currently being
analyzed by children Dale
sorry shift ends day of waking da starts
then he was to learn during his market
master the innocence suggests that sort
of visit another hero who at once lost
and regained his strength we're binding
in buffer Keeley's and he leaves along
with donald compete to visit him on
Olympus Coliseum later Sora realizes
that the limits between the worlds have
been closed but goofy remembers the
innocence saying may your heart be your
guiding key Sora then uses his heart to
some of the gates to Olympus Coliseum
and the three blast off of their ship
meeting us to Kingdom Hearts 3 hey
everybody thank you so much for watching
this video and if you enjoyed it please
give us a like and subscribe for more a
huge thanks goes to elf demon and PM XP
wood from the Kingdom Hearts subreddit
for all their help writing this I'd also
like to thank let me just use some
footage we missed check the description
for their info and leave us a comment on
what series you'd like to see us cover
see you next time
I want to listen can't use keyblades
listen guys this is why sort of reaction
videos to get a lot of crap what do you
mean you didn't retain all hey that was
one of the hardest things the first few
minutes I was like all right okay think
okay I got I got okay I think I got it
just a bit was okay but I'm sure after a
few minutes you know once once this
starts unfolding I'm gonna be able to
you know at least like glad Shawna
what's going on there I wanted the setup
five minutes I'm like oh God oh well get
lost
are we lost there's nobody's people
heartless there's there's people you can
go into people's hearts you can make a
copy of yourself that doesn't have a
heart
yeah there's also copy of you that's
made out of life yeah there's like a
good version of you but then there's
also many these characters have like
five different iterations like oh yeah
this person went missing oh this
person's back I don't really know much
about that person I don't much been
anybody here other than the fact you
said that person's name yeah yeah
becomes a hot putty for twist people are
twisting and turning and everyone comes
in with it I I am revealing my true
identity I actually care I actually
don't care I actually have a plot of my
hand
Mickey is here now hey there's new
members here it's kind of weird that
they're distracting when they're here
see the thing is way back back in the
day when the first game was out the big
draw for me and one of the things I was
most enthused about in playing it was
all the different Disney worlds you get
to visit and all the characters that are
featured in the game and the funniest
thing about this video to me is that
that is almost none of the focus at all
of them yeah the only Disney characters
we really see her Mickey Goofy and
Donald and there's an allusion to Chip
and Dale and like Maleficent but
otherwise like they're they're just a
lot of those so I I clearly at the time
was not latched into the deeper
mythology I was just kind of confused as
to why they're even in the game per se I
stuff I mean don't get me wrong this is
a really well-constructed video yeah I
mean takes a lot of time you gotta write
out a whole script you probably had to
play the games multiple time yeah like
all that footage you had to work through
yeah from like hours and hours and hours
from multiple games like but I really
feel like this is more for people who
need a refresher on Kingdom Hearts this
is not an introduction it's not an
introduction this is a lecture before a
midterm yes I'm like I don't understand
so much it was that's like I kept
catching bits and pieces whenever I
thought I was latching on I was like
nevermind I'm not yeah and then at
certain points during the video like
okay I'm just gonna keep track from here
on yeah I don't exactly know how all the
games are laid out so you're also
jumping back and forth between different
looking graphics and so for a part of it
especially like the earlier part it's
like it took a while to get to those
old-school graphics so I'm sure that
some of the story is out of order in
these games anyway I wasn't expecting it
to be such a dark story he said I was I
was so associated with like the Disney
side of the inclusion of this game that
when it was getting all dark I'm like oh
well I like the fantasy elements too
where do you take things and you make it
literal like oh you know I needs to find
their hearts gone or you know they need
to get in touch with their heart in
order to be able to do something like
really get in touch with the emotional
side of things and how they manifest
into something very physical those
elements I really appreciated you know
like having creatures like nobody so
we're developing hearts yeah yeah yeah
the world is growing every organism kind
of finds its own way to evolve a lot of
the symbolism and everything because I
wasn't expecting something so complex
cuz all I ever heard about it were like
Disney characters right here and then
I'm like oh there's new characters seem
kind of weird when they're on screen I
feel like that's just a clever way to
get people into playing the yeah that
use switcheroo with this whole mythology
which I gotta say like going into this
video as kind of absurd as the reaction
part became it did make me appreciate
just how vast these games are and
appreciate why the fanbase is so
dedicated why people were so excited for
the new game and it actually did make me
want to go back and approach the game
from this direction from the sort of
like alright let's unlock the actual
yeah ology and not just try to get to
the Nightmare Before Christmas world I
really just wish like in order to keep
up with the information of the
characters a little bit more background
like even just quick little details on
the background of them would have helped
out a little bit or you know take this
very newbie and make it seven videos
yeah they're all more spaced out my mind
is really a really burnt out right now
Kairi and Sora and and cloud and and you
know Sephiroth and and Luigi and Samus
and all those somebody in the comments
posted if Disney decided to make their
own Final Fantasy and that's kind of how
this does feel yeah I mean everyone's
names are the same some people look too
much alike that I would forget who they
are yeah and then you have multiple
versions of the same guy so you're like
oh I for a second I thought those were
different yeah but now they're the same
dude and then this dude came back as a
wise guy when he was this guy before and
that he's dead but he's not dead and
then I really am curious though to
figure the game out you know what I want
to play this is I wonder if I play it
I'll understand it yeah like I bet you
that I won't fear that like how am i
more confused yeah well you'll have the
advantage of getting for 40 hours in
dialogue yeah I'm having three games or
they're to two boiled down into 40
minutes it's just like there's a billion
of each thing like xeno [ __ ] it's
different this whole commentary has been
about why we're confused I you know
we're just doing what we can we can just
try and pretend like we know we're
talking about and be like you know I
thought they did a really nice job of
giving a well-rounded game you know this
reminds me of everything that I already
knew and nothing was left out I feel
like this was complete good video thanks
for watching you know you know when you
watch the matrix and you re watching you
get more from it and you understand even
more it's this kind of video we're gonna
do is we're gonna watch it again right
now John had the
double the length of the video alright
guys well we're gonna just sign off now
that was tough thanks Michael B for a
gentle introduction into this I hope you
like that
well we'll catch you on that third game
maybe I